[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony them
[Music]
the jobs are out on Twitter I type in
the word fouchy
[Music]
I've sent out I had a sensitive content
Elon had his feeling curd I guess I
don't know
he doesn't he does not want me to make
fun of the right wing nut jobs on
Twitter for being obsessed with Dr
Anthony bouchi you know why they're
really pissed off
I mean they're they're pissed off
because you know they don't have anyone
to blame from the pandemic but
themselves but the reason why they're
pissed off is because their logic behind
fauci fought is falling apart they lose
the plot every single time
every time these idiots lose the
plot because they're making it up as
they go along they really don't have any
long-term strategy as far as what is
politically necessary to win elections
anymore they're only trying to get
um the sound bites on Fox News News Max
and oan
but they're losing their narrative
because they're blaming vouchy for the
pandemic for the Wuhan he was sponsored
for the Wuhan league and this is
probably going to get me turned
off on YouTube too because I'm saying
these words
but here's the thing
and which we're going to talk about
freedom of speech
um I'm not gonna address Scott Adams too
directly but I am going to talk about
freedom of speech so I am going to talk
about that I think that's an important
issue to talk about but anyways
back to fauci in the right wing nut jobs
who are losing the plot on fauci uh the
problem is if you blame
Wuhan the Wuhan leak on fauci and he he
unleashed the pandemic on the world then
you lose your narrative that it was all
and you didn't need to social
distance and mask my asking oh the virus
was fake and thank you
I mean you you start to lose the plot
you start to lose the narrative and and
this is why they will continue to do
this nonsense is because they're all
Alex jonesed up
on information
and it is an information war that we're
in Marjorie Taylor green is calling for
a civil war but we already have one
we already have a world war three and
it's an information War it's what it is
there
they're now claiming
they're now Glam again they're now
claiming that the entirety of the the uh
the Ukrainian conflict where Vladimir
Putin uh entered their Sovereign Nation
and tried to steal their democracy from
them
and the Ukrainian people said no you're
not you're not no no this is our
country you're not gonna take our
country
they're saying all that is all
made up now it's all false flag
Russia's really not there ukrainian's
really not fighting all those videos
that you've seen of Vladimir Putin
committing war crimes at didn't exist
because because they're losing the plot
they're losing the plot that's why they
have to blame all the deaths in the
world on the pandemic on Anthony fauci
as if Anthony fauci is the one
responsible for all the deaths in the
world
we know we know we know who Anthony
fauci is now we we didn't know who he
was before Trump used him as the
scapegoat for the blame
of his dereliction of his duty to the
American people during 2020 during the
pandemic
we know he is now we wouldn't know who
the Anthony fauci was if Hillary
Clinton would have been president
let's just play a little game Let's
rewind the clock
and say that that people actually got
out and voted and and knew that it was
quite the risk to have some
lunatic in the office of the presidency
even by technicality
of the Electoral College
and they went and voted in Pennsylvania
and Wisconsin and Michigan they went and
actually got off their asses and went
out and voted
instead of self-suppressing their vote
thank you thank you you self-suppressing
liberals
that's what I and tyt are you listening
that's what I keep railing about but
let's say let's say those
self-suppressed votes actually went
and cast their ballot for democracy
and and for sanity
you wouldn't know who Anthony foutchi is
you would have no clue not a
goddamn clue you wouldn't hear his name
you wouldn't know who he is because
Hillary Clinton would have been there in
the Forefront she would have took all
the responsibility all the
accountability because she's a
leader that's what she would have done
that's what all the other leaders did
for all the other epidemics that we had
that Anthony fauci
where he was the head of NIH and no one
knew who the he was
I mean he was there he was there but he
wasn't a public figure in the sense
that politicians wanted him to use him
as a scapegoat
because their orange Mussolini Jesus
failed
he does this all the time he does this
all the time
when he when he loses
I mean this is a pattern for this
slob
when he loses he blames someone or
something else
and fauci is there is their scapegoat
for their failure of course they're like
oh see we were correct we were right
about natural immunity no one doubted
natural immunity you turds not a
single person it it's a thing natural
immunity it's a thing the thing
that they were arguing against is that
it was killing hundreds of thousands of
Americans at a very quick clip so
natural immunity really wasn't a very
viable option if you didn't want stacks
of dead bodies everywhere
foreign
about natural immunity you killed over a
million people here great great going on
the natural immunity thing you
anti-vaxxers
they were right about the Wuhan lamp
you're not right about the Wuhan lab the
reports are is that there's very little
evidence that exists
that it was taken out of the lab you
boneheads
you take these crumbles these crumbles
that don't even resemble truth anymore
and you're trying to spin your narrative
and they lose the plot every
time every single mother time
they lose the plot and they will
continue to lose the plot
and we should lean into this
that's why I keep telling you that Ron
DeSantis is not going to be their
nominee it is going to be Donald Trump
it listen to me listen I know it's it
it's scary I talked to someone over the
weekend a good friend of mine
and he asked me he asked me he said do
you think Donald Trump
he doesn't listen to the show he knows I
have the show he knows I know about
politics and I follow it and he follows
it enough to know that Donald Trump is a
lying cheating fat slug who's a traitor
to our Constitution and a danger to our
democracy frankly it was a sentiment
that I took from him but he asked if I
thought that Donald Trump
would be the nominee I said I I 100 I
know he will be
and he got a little he got a little
scared
because then we brought up Ron DeSantis
and uh
he didn't seem as scared about Ron
DeSantis
right
and I told him I said the problem is Ron
DeSantis does not have the courage he's
a coward and he doesn't have the courage
to stand up to Donald Trump and his
supporters he just doesn't have the
wherewithal to do it I don't believe I
mean Maybe I'm Wrong we'll see if
Florida's Hitler decides to enter the
race now the news is over the weekend
that he's rounding up Trump donors
that's not going to matter folks do you
think Donald Trump facing indictment in
prison time is going to give a what
donors Ron DeSantis has
yeah honestly I'm not cheering for Trump
but I I want him to be their nominee I
that's what I want it's what I want I
want them to have to pay for that
I want to have them to pay
for their Dirty Deeds
these are their Dirty Deeds
these are these are not Trump's Dirty
Deeds anymore them still hanging on to
that that treasonous piece of
garbage is their dirty deed not his
he's just he's just hanging on for dear
life they're the ones that that aren't
letting Jack go into the cold water
let him die you idiots but they
don't want him to die folks they don't
have any other platform they don't have
any other Foundation of belief
other than Trump and trumpism it's a
cult
and a lot of people are out there are
believing the nonsense of the cult even
though they're not full-on card holding
members
but this friend of mine was very
concerned I mean he was it felt like he
got physically uncomfortable when I told
him yes Donald Trump is going to be the
nominee
and then he asked me about Joe Biden I
said Joe Biden will be the nominee and
he will win
uh this morning
oh on the other side on the other on on
our side this morning there's a poll of
of democratic nominees again you should
not pay attention to polls at all so if
you see him on Twitter mock them or move
on one of the other but this morning
people are bitching that Bernie Sanders
isn't in the Democratic nominations uh
running for who's gonna be at the top
it's it's going to be Joe Biden
No No One's Gonna Run against him no one
good luck
who's gonna run against him you point
out you tell me on Twitter who you
think's gonna run against him and and
I'll I'll tell you I told you so when
they don't they're pissed off this
morning that Bernie Sanders is not part
of that poll
the reason why Bernie Sanders is not
part of the democratic nominees poll is
because Bernie Sanders is not a Democrat
he's not he's an independent him and
Angus King caucus with the Democrats to
make 51. that's the Democratic caucus in
the Senate he's not a Democrat why would
he show up on a democratic nominees poll
he's not even in the Democratic party
these people really don't understand
politics they don't understand our
government they don't understand Civics
and they want to act like they know what
the they're talking about
and they don't they just don't
it's the same stupid thing with fauci
you're talking about things you just
have no clue what you're saying
and that's fine they have the First
Amendment right to speech
but we also have the right to know that
they're really their speech is really
really dumb and sometimes really
racist in the form of Scott Adams now
I'm not going to address too hard on
Scott Adams
I really don't give a about him I
don't
there's a lot of cartoonists in this
world some that are racist some that are
not he clearly is he clearly has been
for a long time
and it's a shame it's a shame that some
art in this country
is packed away and stuffed away because
their artists are just
and scumbags I mean R Kelly there's
another example
you can't even hardly listen to an R
Kelly song Anymore without understanding
he was talking about having sex with
children
it's difficult good art good songs you
love the beat
you love the look oh man it's good stuff
but man when you understand the context
of it oh it just you can't do it
anymore
you can't do it
and for these freedom freedom of
speech freedom of speech
speaking freedom of speech I don't know
if you saw the um the tweet I sent out
so I went over to the podcast account I
always retweet the broadcast uh for
whatever reason my software Elon does
not want me to broadcast from the
podcast to count on Twitter so I have to
broadcast from my personal account
that's why it always ends up there and I
don't know I I tried it a thousand times
and tried to fix it yeah it I'm
just I'm not I'm over it
I don't give a
the of magnitude is real trust me
so
I I I I broadcast this show from my
Twitter account because for whatever
reason I can't broadcast from the
podcast account whatever reason maybe
stay I don't have Twitter blue or some
I don't know
the point is this
is that this morning when I went to go
retweet uh from the podcast account
um Twitter had marked
had marked my content as as sensitive
because the title of the show is fauci
owns right-wing nut jobs
that's the title of the show found she
owns right-wing net jobs they he lives
rent free inside their heads for
whatever reason I can't all honestly
figure it out and I know why they're
pissed off I'll get to that that the
right-wing nut jobs they're mad at the
house Republican house members and it's
gonna get worse for them
it's gonna get worse
but anyways I I will lay that aside for
a second but um at this for these first
amendment they they they banned me and
not banned me but they they blocked it
as sensitive content now you might be
able to see it depending on how you have
your sensitive content settings on
Twitter
um but I I can't see it on that account
so I took a picture and I tagged Yvonne
and I said that Twitter is canceling my
broadcast because I put a word that
rhymes with ouchy
I figured he might see it
and idiot
Elon Elon you dumbass
um anyways so back to freedom of speech
and what it really means because you I
you know I actually believe that in the
case of Scott Adams or anyone like him
anyone like him again I'm not going to
go into his his specific comments if you
want to go see him you go see him he's a
racist
but I mean it's Scott Adams and anyone
else in this country has the freedom
they have the Liberty to be a racist
they really do
if you don't if you don't understand
that if you fundamentally don't know
that people have the right to be a
racist they have a right to hold racist
beliefs now they can't act on them those
could be hate crimes but they can hold
racist beliefs they can believe racist
things
that is a thing you can do in this
country and you can actually voice your
racist opinions
even though they're dumb stupid and
Antiquated and ridiculous
and and not Tethered to any kind
of reality or fact whatsoever
but you know that's fine
and he wanted to do that on the internet
even better now we know who you are
for sure there's no walking it back
there's no re-talking it we know who you
are we know how you feel and you used
your your First Amendment right to show
us that
the places where they publish his art
they also have the First Amendment right
to tell him to off
what don't people understand about this
you're not getting canceled you
ass you're not getting
canceled people just are not gonna
tolerate your intolerance anymore
so if you're going to spew your
intolerance out in the open be prepared
to suffer consequences
of your intolerance
now over the weekend I I played a video
from a drag queen Story Hour at a
library where some Pastor showed up oh
they're they're they're Warriors of God
eating hating people hating other human
beings their fellow countrymen oh my God
they're Servants of Jesus by hating
people it's really stupid
they got thrown out like literally you
got thrown out of this event
oh it's a great video to watch you get
thrown on his ass
they practically opened the door with
his head
I mean I'm not saying that's what you
should do but I'm saying that's what you
should do
probably more than likely maybe
depending on that probably not depending
on engage every case length that that
they enter into the drag shoe where
they're in there causing a ruckus you
should uh escort them out and use their
head to open the door
honestly there's another video going
around of uh some trumped-up dude uh
approaching uh an interracial couple on
the street
and and and spewing some bigotry with
his phone in their face man I don't know
when we stop punching Nazis in
this country
but and I'm not promoting violence but
I'm just saying I don't know when that
when that stopped happening
these people are gonna face some
situation and some consequences
eventually it's gonna happen people are
not gonna put up with your intolerance
we we shouldn't have to tolerate that
in our society it's 2023 for crying
out loud we have to put up with your
bigotry out in the open we just
don't you can have it you can talk about
it you can go make an internet video
about it but when your gets when
your gets shut down because no one
wants anything to do with your opinion
don't be bitching quit whining you
little quit whining
quit your whining
stop acting like everyone's targeting
you and you're targeting your hate
towards people and making it known out
in the wide open world with your First
Amendment right and then whine and cry
that you had consequences
is white privilege is really
getting on my nerves it really
truly is
it's so ridiculous
it's it's just it's just
insanity
that you think you have the right to be
as racist as you want to be and keep
everything you got with no consequence
especially when you do it out in the
open just you don't talk to your other
racist little friends on the phone or
something
or talk to him in person if you don't
want to accidentally be recorded I'm
just saying you know what I mean
Jesus Christ quit your whining when you
put your opinions out on the internet
and what was I going to get oh yes
speaking opinions on the internet now
these little right-wing nut jobs these
trolls they're freaking out over Anthony
fauci right
the one reason why they're really pissed
off and they're the politicians and the
masses the Q Anon masses are losing
their grip on the plot
is because the Republicans like and
first thing we'll do is we'll fire IRS
agents thousands hundreds millions of
them Marjorie Taylor green fired 6
billion IRS agents last week alone last
week alone she fired 6 billion I don't
know she likes the word billion
but another promise they made is they
were going to hang Anthony fauci at The
Gallows at gitmo remember this was going
to be one of their things oh yeah they
went around the country we're gonna hold
him accountable
we're gonna lock him up
I haven't had to Anthony fauci not
a goddamn thing they won't they can't
they they can't
it's really stupid
but I'm telling you they're gonna get
more pissed off and more pissed off and
more pissed off
the more that Anthony fauci is not hung
at gitmo
and we should point it out
that that the Republicans are such
failures that they can't help the
American people and they can't keep
their promises
they couldn't lock Hillary Clinton up
Donald Trump failed at that
and they can't lock Anthony fauci up or
Hunter Biden you've failed
you failures we should point it
out we should use it as a wedge issue
because Jesus Christ
almost 99 of these Q Anon freaks
that's all they care about is fouchy in
a laptop
they don't give a about anything
else
but again they're losing the plot
because they keep turning these
narratives on their heads
they're starting to switch
sides
from being American to being
anti-American
out in the open not not code words even
it's not even code word anymore
they're in they're in big trouble folks
and we've got them on the run but we
can't stop
We Can't Stop Now
I'm telling you the Cheeto does q an
honor their orange Mussolini Jesus is
going to be the nominee
barring some accident where he chokes on
a Big Mac
or he can't get down a full bucket of
chicken
maybe a leg gets caught in his windpipe
or something I don't know I'm just
saying
what do you want from me he eats a lot
of chicken and cheeseburgers so I'm just
assuming if he would choke on something
that's that's what would happen
I don't know
barring something like that I just don't
see how he's not going to get the
nomination here
a lot of the pundits over the weekend
were like oh Ron DeSantis oh he's gay
he's attracting those donors
those Trump donors are leaving him oh
baby
so what
so what you think he's gonna give a
if he's got money or not he's he didn't
have money at the beginning of 2020
2016.
he didn't have any money he
didn't have big donors he didn't have
him he'll get him
as soon as he starts winning primaries
and it's clear that he's going to be the
eventual nominee they will jump in
if you don't believe me just go look at
any Republican out there that's
done an interview where the interviewer
has asked them if they think Donald
Trump would be the nominee they're like
oh well I don't think he'll be and then
they say well if he is will you vote for
him well I I would have to vote for the
Republican
we have to vote for the I mean even
though he's a treasonous piece of
we still have to vote for him
foreign
they're not Americans anymore they're
anti-americans
have you watched Tucker Carlson lately
what these people are listening to and
again I'm not saying half the country
yeah a lot of people get that twisted
half the country is not for Trump
and not even not even for full-on
trumpism
there's a large swath of the country who
vote based on affiliation and they'll
vote for him oh yeah
in the 30s in the 40s they'll vote for
the son of a believe it
but they're not full on trumpers
because they vote for Association
but I'm telling you as he wins these
primaries as he ticks through these
primaries you think Nikki Haley's gonna
win a primary out of here with that
you you think if Ron DeSantis gets in
Donald Trump won't torch him
which I believe that's why he's not
getting in
Ron DeSantis doesn't want to ruin his
political career and Donald Trump will
do certainly that that's what I'm hoping
for
that's what I told my friend this
weekend who was terrified that Donald at
the end at the prospect of Donald Trump
being the nominee or Ron DeSantis for
that matter
and I told him I said there is no better
battle that we want in this world than
Ronda santis and and and Donald Trump
now I believe that Ron DeSantis won't
get in so that's what I feel
no way if I'm Ron DeSantis and I can run
in 2028 why in the would I try to
and absolutely
kill my career
over this idiot
no way he he's been he's been working
too hard at his fascism in Florida
to ruin it
on this bonehead
and I talked about a little bit uh uh
Florida over the weekend and we're going
to touch on it more on this uh this drag
show thing I'm gonna show the full video
yesterday on the patreon on Sunday docs
if you guys don't know on patreon I do
extra content this show is free Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
for two full hours
on YouTube Twitter twitch and
simulcasting for Facebook
but I do a show I'm not a show it's just
a it's just a hangout type thing on
Sundays on patreon it's called Sunday
talk so we've been doing it the last few
weeks so if you want to check that out
just go to patreon.com slash the Tony
Michaels or go to the Tony michaels.com
and hit the patreon link there and you
can find out more about it
you'll be seeing these things pop up on
YouTube I'm gonna post them on YouTube
several weeks after I've done them and
and everyone on patreon has had a chance
to to watch them
um so they'll they'll appear they'll be
out of date because I'll be talking
about stuff that happened four weeks ago
but you'll get a chance to see them of
what they are so if you're interested in
seeing what the patreons are about again
just go to the Tony michaels.com
and check it out there we got a big week
ahead of us I have a feeling a big week
ahead of us that this morning and
there's more sentencing of the January
6th
insurrectionist
um also
uh looks like uh
let's see what else do we have oh oh the
um there is EPA news the EPA is in Ohio
the federal government is in Ohio making
sure that Norfolk Southern is held
accountable to where they're taking the
contaminated dirt to states are
pissed off that they might be bringing
in their states so the EPA is there when
you know it federal government the ones
that the big government the big
government that the Republicans love now
now that it's in Ohio they love it in
Ohio not anywhere else
well and they they love big government
and and in a woman's body
science and in drag shoes and in
libraries and you know what they they do
just love big oppressive government uh
in general everyone stick around we'll
be right back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
good Monday
it always is
how many billions
Marjorie Taylor green atmosphere put out
a video
look I'm not seeing the CrossFit
he isn't you know a decent
strategy for exercise but it looks
stupid
it looks dumb
I mean you know there's I I guess it
depends on what your goals are
but if your goal is to pretend to do
pull-ups
um and look like you're doing pull-ups
and to pretend like you're strong or
something
then yeah sure CrossFit yeah go ahead
and if you're a crossfitter out there
why why are you doing CrossFit why just
just lift weights you really don't have
to punish your joints you don't
have to it's not a thing you have to do
if you really want Mobility to stretch
okay on your off days of lifting just
stretch just do that
you can get really flexible and
stretching right
like you know you don't have to punish
your joints
and do really stupid stuff with your
body
it looks dumb and there there's there's
no reason for it
so if you do do CrossFit out there but
you I guess if you do it to enjoy it you
know I'm fine whatever I guess it it
looks
stupid
it looks dumb
um
hey now let's see John I don't know
maybe John maybe John normally disagrees
with me he says CrossFit is unhealthy
and he's right about stretching oh
you're right about straight yeah I think
John is here increasing me most times
sorry I thought you were someone else
CrossFit is stupid it's really dumb it's
it's hard on your joints it causes
injury
like it would it would be like someone
who's trying to get in shape and they're
like here put these football pads on
you're gonna play with some elite
players and they're gonna crush you like
they're gonna oh man they're gonna slam
into you they're gonna they're gonna
really hit you hard like why would you
do that
why
you're not an athlete you're you're not
you're not an athlete it's not your
profession
okay
so why would you do that
like honestly and John I mean I know
um John thinks I'm correct but I am I am
right on this just lift weights do
strength training
and stretch you bonehead oh man
and and again if you're if you're if
you're here and you watch every day and
you do CrossFit
I am I'm really sorry I'm really sorry
uh Roy says what is CrossFit just go
Google that
oh wait you know what don't John or Roy
Roy excuse me Roy don't go anywhere I'm
gonna show you
I'm gonna show you what CrossFit is I'm
gonna show you what it is it's really
stupid it's really dumb
and wouldn't you know Marjorie Taylor
green loves it
she loves it she loves it
um and Erica makes a good point she says
maybe it'll destroy Marjorie Taylor
green
out you know
I don't wish
um joint tears on anyone
oh her oh
I mean that Peggy points out yoga is
yeah yoga is a good stretching exercise
if you want to stretch but I mean you
don't have to do Yogi you can just do
static stretches I mean there's a lot of
static stretches especially if you have
a certain joints or or certain muscles
that you want to stretch
it was my you can't really stretch a
joint I mean you can
when you're doing CrossFit and you
stretch it you know
out of place and you rip it tear it
um
there's Sabrina says dang right Tony I
blew my knee out on a treadmill
again
you gotta be careful exercising I don't
run hey I got a bad ankle and bad knees
I was in a car accident long time ago
and so I I mean I can run okay you
all you out there who think I I can run
I choose not to run
because I I'm more prone to injury
because I'm running so I walk
it's not rocket science
and one walk it's just logic right you
got to get exercise you get you know
walk a little bit
right
but this this CrossFit stuff
is um someone says Pilates is amazing
and Christina says Pilates is amazing
yeah my wife likes Pilates over yoga I
think she prefers Pilates
over yoga now Jane says no walking is
great that's one of the best exercises
you should you should walk you should do
that if you can if you can't walk get on
a bike and pedal
right even if you're not pedaling very
fast you just gotta move a little bit
your body is your mind your mind is your
body so if you're moving your mind's
moving that's what I find I sit in this
chair for three hours four hours
a day
I have to get up I gotta move around
so I that's why I go take my walks well
I walk a mile and I have two miles I try
to do it four five six times a week
being on the weather
but but it helps it helps you know get
you out of your element you can help get
you out of your chair
this CrossFit stuff is stupid
it's really dumb there's no need for it
[Laughter]
oh
foggy Ozarks she must be in Missouri she
said Tony deepwoods cougars and bears
are attacking humans for food more don't
go out there without protection
it ain't like it used to be I got
protection
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding I I I
I I
could hey I wouldn't outrun a cougar
because I don't run and I'd probably not
be a very good match for a bear either
oh yeah uh Jan points out margin Taylor
green taught CrossFit and I know she
taught CrossFit but she owns our part
part owns a CrossFit gym that's where
the whole tantric sex guru Affair comes
in because apparently he was running her
CrossFit gym
but um that's one reason why CrossFit
got really popular is because you could
open up a CrossFit gym and you'd have to
spend a lot of money on equipment like a
traditional gym it's hundreds of
thousands of dollars to buy all the
equipment the CrossFit gym you have you
have stations right and the stations you
know there's a lot of bar stations
but but there's not a lot that you have
equipment that they have to buy so
um it's just not as expensive to open up
a warehouse CrossFit gym and you can you
you do it in a warehouse you don't have
to have like a special kind of it can be
done in a big ass garage type thing
that's usually where they they have
these things
hey Debbie Dunn CrossFit I wouldn't do
it
after you watch what Marjorie Taylor
green does it
um let's shoot the for a minute
Everyone likes to shoot the let's
continue to do this if you guys got
questions for me let's shoot the
um yeah ask the question here we're
waiting on Gabe Sanchez anyways we're
waiting on that that and Mondays are not
his day okay Monday mornings sometimes I
gotta warm up I gotta send him several
notifications
uh for him to finally uh you know
I'm notifying him again I'm pinging him
again let's shoot the see if you
got any uh questions for me to start the
week uh someone says what's up
and sparklers looks like
we got sparklers and here we always have
uh sparklers in here shout out to all
the sparklers
I I like the sparklers having them here
you got any questions for me this
morning
uh oh he says he he says he's coming on
is Gabe crossfitting now let me see if I
can get this garment yeah I'll hide that
one get down going there we go it's Gabe
CrossFit I don't think Gabe does
CrossFit I don't know but if he does
we're totally gonna make fun of him for
it
for sure for sure Gabe if Gabe does
CrossFit I'm totally gonna make fun of
it for it but I'm not I'm not 100 sure
um why Tony why am I so sure that Biden
will win against Trump why am I so sure
listen
um it is it's a very difficult task
to overcome an 8 million vote deficit
it's a very difficult task
um and and he had a three million uh
vote deficit in 2016 and it grew to 8
million in 2020. it's only likely to
grow more to 2024 and my my best guess
is at this point February 27th
uh 2023 we're not even
um we're not close to the 2024 election
but my guess is is that Joe Biden will
beat Donald Trump by almost 12 million
votes
it's my best guess so that's how much
it'll grow
it's it's not it's not going it's it you
can't he can't outrun statistics it's
not gonna do it right now I I'm not one
to press data and
I I just don't
right I'm not gonna pile you with a
bunch of data and stats and
nonsense this isn't NPR you
didn't come here to get bored to come
here to be entertained and listen to
politics and get a cathartic release
and and for someone who
objectively understands that liberalism
is strength
but that's why I know that's why I'm
very positive and very sure because
there's no way that Joe Biden's not
going to be the Democratic nominee trust
me it's not going to happen there he's
not gonna have a challenger this morning
the Bernie Sanders people are pissed off
this morning because
um he they don't even have him on the
pole and that's because Bernie Sanders
isn't going to challenge Joe but no
one's going to challenge Jill Biden no
one would challenge his record they
would lose okay they would
lose against Joe Biden's
incumbent record
it's not gonna happen
um
Melanie asked on on Facebook do I
actually sleep I sleep yeah I sleep
yeah about six seven hours a night it's
usually what I get I like eight but I
usually can't sleep that long
uh let's see here
other questions
um this question marky's got a tag from
Tim t
do you do I think Don Jr does coke
does does a bear in the woods I
mean is that really a question
what's my favorite color uh my favorite
colors are gray black and blue
that's that's my favorite colors but uh
you know I can be persuaded for red
you know that black is probably my
favorite color I like wearing black I
mean that's what I like to wear
you know gray black oh let's see
new
let's see what other questions do we
have
uh have I seen the interview with
Michael Cohen interviewing Leb Barnes no
I probably won't either I don't have I
don't have time to watch that
I wish I did have time to watch it but I
don't I mean
I like Michael and I like that Lev you
know Parnes did what he did come out
publicly but and it probably won't
probably not sorry
um Gabe Sanchez there was a question
earlier we're shooting the so we're
talking about CrossFit and house yeah
the CrossFit CrossFit they were asking
do you do you do don't you uh I used to
do CrossFit yeah
I I said I don't think he does but we're
gonna make fun of him if he does no not
anymore I uh I stopped doing it uh no I
didn't get injured I mean I've read
stories about uh the injuries that
happened the permanent damage that can
happen oh oh man okay everyone I didn't
do that I promised that wasn't me
turning him off because um because
uh I swear I did not do that that was um
something on his end
but uh go ahead and um
CrossFit Gabe
who wants who wants to see uh CrossFit
Gabe if there's any video I want to see
CrossFit game Amanda said uh Lev Barn is
spilled on Rudy I mean yeah
that that's that's why I keep saying
stop you know getting so upset that Rudy
hasn't paid a price yet they're not
there yet with him
they got Lev they got him
do we have any other questions
um
do you do you I think uh the U.S will
end up going to war with Russia China no
no
I do not think that that that's why
they're yelling and screaming about it
when the right wing is yelling and
screaming about something you can pretty
well bet
then it's all
almost every time it's complete utter
just like this I mean is there
situations is there scenarios that can
happen over a period of time sure that
depends on how long Putin is willing to
commit to his war crimes
and how long he last uh okay let's see
if we can um how are you there CrossFit
game I don't know what's going on man
you know I I suppose the crosstalk I
don't know I did switch my camera last
night to a different one oh yeah so I'm
not this one is this one the one that
you used to film yourself doing CrossFit
because we want CrossFit videos I used
to film myself yeah really no no I never
oh come on no the only time anyone I
never said there's no evidence there's
no evidence of you doing CrossFit other
than you're admitting it I mean there
might be a photo
foreign
there's no I never took any videos of
myself it would typically be other
people taking videos I see I like a
group because most of the time most of
the time like CrossFit is like a group
thing where you have stations see you're
you're killing it again
this new camera sucks
yeah he's he's gonna adjust it oh man
he's you're gonna have to go back to
your normal camera I think
[Music]
um
rainbow rainbow Gabe they're calling it
rainbow Gabe CrossFit Gabe let's see
um
what's my favorite 80s TV theme song
well uh I mean I guess it started in the
80s
so the one that I like the best probably
and it's not really a theme song I guess
maybe Fresh Prince of Bel-Air but like
uh the Seinfeld Diddy rank because I
like Seinfeld Patrick Sullivan asked
that I got Margie's comment up here
she's just trying to grab your your
questions and point them out to me so
Patrick asked that question I hope that
answers your question
um
oh someone said um
and they loved the latest what was that
so when we get gay back on we'll make
fun of him for CrossFit we'll tell them
that people are admiring his uh what was
that you guys should go watch that piece
of content for sure
let's see
um
the gate got crossed out uh well
um let's see what else do we have any
other questions that you get while we're
shooting the
and while we're waiting for Gabe Sanchez
to come on back for the shitless Roundup
because we do have the in this
Roundup we got to get through he wants
to talk about Elon Musk today
um for some reason I'm not sure exactly
what there's a fake Elon Musk post going
around that um is supporting Scott Adams
it's fake it's not real I went to check
on it
oh oh someone's you guys are talking to
each other I don't know if you're asking
me questions sometimes are we asking uh
mighty librarian says how am I feeling
today it's Monday
I'm always happy to get back on the air
this is my happy place
this is my happy spot that I'm in when I
do the show it's what I like doing
I love doing this every single day I
love coming here and talking about
politics about narrative about National
messaging I love talking to you folks I
love hanging out with you I really like
this shoot the the thing that we're
doing again I promise I'll try to get
some
some demons but I'm kind of lazy
you know what I mean I just
again
um
uh let's see another question here is uh
the backyard bear ask
what got you started doing the podcast
what started me doing the podcast let's
see if we can get Gabe Sanchez's um
camera work in here and then I'll answer
this question I I figured out what
happened
the I use a DSLR and yeah I swapped one
out because there was some weird setting
because I was the DSR your image card
no the DSLR was had it but when I
switched it I forgot that there was a
one minute auto shut off so basically we
were having one minute conversations
why the hell is this happening anyway
perfect for clips and reels you know
yeah they can only be 60 seconds long
yeah yeah so um
and then I'll answer the question about
the butt I did CrossFit I moved here in
LA in 2018 so I started doing it then uh
and then I stopped in 2019. now wait now
wait wait like like about a year or a
little bit over a year because because
you auditioned for a lot of stuff right
yeah so was it like hey I gotta get into
shape so I can audition for these things
the reason was because that was a part
of a gym in San Francisco that was like
a hit style gym yeah hit is a little
different than CrossFit no I know kind
of the same but it's close it's similar
in that you're doing you know multiple
circuits and a fixed amount of time in
its high intensity so in that regard uh
uh I was like I need to find something
that's close to it and then I was like
I'll just take you know look for a gym
and then I found this one that was like
down the street and they offered a
variety of classes and then I was like
oh well also I can throw in weight
training as well so I just did that yeah
and then it was the CrossFit is hard on
your body though yeah
no no I never got up I think the
only ever the only time I ever had like
an injury was when
I kind of strained my lower back but I
but these those snatches were you
snatching when you did that or were you
no it was when I was I was dead lifting
but I was deadlifting like you know I
don't know how much weight but it was
enough where like I was like I should
have worn a belt but I didn't wear a
belt yeah and I just had to wear a belt
when I dropped it yeah but here's the
somebody uh Steve says what is hit hit
is high intensity interval training
it's yeah so it's just like a series of
actually it's a psych or a cycle of
exercise is that you're doing at high
intensity and you don't put breaks in
between yeah like when you're strength
training you're lifting weights like
you'll bench press and then you wait
three or four minutes to go to your next
set right with hit you just go from set
to set to set to set to set so you've
got like and the the thing that hit and
Crossfit the reason that they're so
similar the reason that I jumped over
was because they've got uh
uh there's imams which is every minute
on the minute so that's you know for 60
seconds you're doing this thing and then
you switch over clock changes then the
next minute you're doing this thing and
you're just doing a cycle or a circuit
um so in that way it was also fun
because you're doing it with a bunch of
other people so there's like this oh I
have to do it not just like that okay
you drove to the gym and now what's on
you to do you know that was the thing
that I enjoyed the most about doing that
style uh across it in particular it's
just it's just the the
group of people together now working
together well was yours in like a
warehouse because I was saying that
earlier like these crossfits yeah
there's a lot of I mean like because
they're very minimalist in the sense
like all right yeah uh this one wasn't
in a warehouse it did have like a brick
wall exposed kind of feel with like
matting it was pretty open but it wasn't
a warehouse it was like a a business
that you know and then they I guess they
relocated I thought they shut down but
during
um
uh during uh covet but I guess it came
back yeah I got you again well I again I
said earlier if you're gonna do CrossFit
just lift weights and stretch you ain't
gotta batter your joints because that's
it's not only that but there's also it's
called Uncle robdo and uncle robdo is
this condition if anyone who's done
CrossFit and I just want to make sure I
get it right uncle
Rob dough yeah
um but basically it's um
oh here we go uncle robdo is the cartoon
humorously referencing the CrossFit
literature representative as a troubling
Trend among crossfitters which basically
is
uh it's robdo
rhabdomyolysis
no well you see it a lot in your arm
like people are just like go from like
muscle to they just like stretch it out
and it's just like uh it's just like a
loose rubber band is basically what it
looks like so then you go from this like
big muscle to not only this thing is
just like flabbing around
um anyway so it's it's basically from
over exerting your body and it happens
in Crossfit because you're doing these
things for strenuous things too I mean
here's the thing CrossFit it does get
you in great shape but for a lot of
people who are inexperienced or people
who are kind of rushing that development
you know because every day is a PR for
someone who's new to CrossFit so you're
trying to push and push and push and
then eventually you you might injure
yourself and so that's what happens so
that's like the other thing the other
thing too is KRON Spin A lot of times
these people aren't they're not
they're not they don't have the mobility
to even do CrossFit and they just jump
into CrossFit like that it's not
and like if you're if you're a teenager
in your early 20s your body can take
that kind of punishment because
you've got a lot of stretch a lot of
Mobility when you're younger but as you
get older
it's not a thing you got you just don't
have these Achy Breaky joints one thing
one question I got for you yeah what's
up then I want to know and I think we
asked I think I asked this a couple
weeks ago but were you on gear at all
did you do you do gear oh no man
what no no HGH
like I do know that I do know that
people uh like men in their
like 50s or whatever they don't take
gear they'll take uh they'll take like
trt uh right they'll take steroids just
for just everything's gear though right
and by people that don't know gear is
like steroids or enhancement drugs yeah
like a lot of people take creatine which
that's a natural thing but it's still
gearing you're still I mean if if you're
tracking your protein if you're eating a
lot of protein you're gearing you're
you're I don't know I'm not sure that's
the same thing it's a natural gear but I
you know look at this are you Natty Yeah
well yeah yeah look if you're having the
question of like are you are you Natty
or you're not right Natty you're not uh
it's I love now on steroids I drink
Natty I drink Maddie I haven't had I
haven't had a Natty light
since I was in college
you were in the midwest you haven't been
you haven't had that's what I grew up on
I grew up on them that's you know I was
raised on natty light so yeah it's
something something it's um the question
I'll answer before we go to the shitless
Roundup is um backyard bear said uh what
got you started doing the podcast I told
the story a few times
um as everyone knows Gabe Sanchez is a
famous dick talker uh I have I don't
have quite the fame on Tic Tac but
that's how I started I actually started
doing my walking rants I was telling you
earlier that I walk for exercise like
that's I can't run why I it's something
I can't run I just I would get injured
if I did yeah you know also running is a
high impact sport there are other things
other exercises that you can do walking
or you know you could do the elliptical
or there's other things that are low
intensity low intensity but have a high
right but but my my knees and my ankles
are ass they really are so
I can't I can't run I can run I just
choose not to well my ankles and my
knees decide not to so I used to walk
and I would do a walking rant and people
love The Walking rant and it turned into
a 30 minute podcast once a week into an
hour once a week and then I got this guy
helping me out and we went to uh two
hours every week and then we went to two
hours every single day so that's how we
got here I mean I'm glad we're here it
seems like a hell of a process over a
two-year period but we're here so I like
I like this um shoot this where
we're just you know talking and they're
asking questions
um oh by the way by the way so
everyone's been talking about what was
that oh last what was that the last
couple and they thought they were pretty
hilarious nice
um I'm working on a new one right now
which is on um
uh it's on I well actually I actually on
Sunday yesterday I had my first uh group
kind of um
uh live q a whoa it was good you know
um great had some did some chatting uh
talked about this week's episode which
is yeah going to well there might be two
to speak but this week for sure is going
to be about
um
Mike Lindell says he's gonna Sue Kevin
McCarthy and take him the Supreme Court
yeah oh those tan sex tapes yeah he's
gonna get him that way he can prove that
there was and they were trying to over I
don't know what they're trying to prove
I really don't get there I mean it's
funny because even Steve Bannon was like
dude don't urinate do this don't do this
yeah there's no he has no legal standing
it's unfair but it's not illegal right
well I I actually believe that
um just like this faucy stuff today
they're gonna lose the narrative with
this 40 000 take Tucker is totally gonna
this up for him he's totally gonna
this up for him they're gonna it's
gonna lead him down a trail that's gonna
be even more lies and it's gonna
it's gonna bite him in the ass
it really is over the weekend there was
um
it was white nationalist
white Christian nationalists that were
protesting Governor dewine's house in
Ohio because they want him to resign
because now he's responsible
telling you they can't you just keep
pounding the drum we keep yelling and
screaming and eventually the fever will
break we're getting there it's happening
we just got it I mean the freedom caucus
is they don't listen to anyone
McCarthy they're unless like right these
people are running wild throwing
at the walls and like what's gonna
stick and nothing sticks it's just like
it just smells really bad like
trees it smells really bad it smells
it's like you really gotta smear that
in you know right but they throw it
on the wall and they look at like ah
it's stuck great and then they like go
over to the next thing and they throw
that on the wall but while they're
doing it that falls off the wall
and it's a big mess and it's just like
they don't learn dude they do not learn
like like I said before they do not
future proof their ideas so they think
in that moment we got them right and
that's that's what that slips the plot
away from them right like this fouchy
thing they're like this morning like oh
fauci's responsible for the pain I
thought the pandemic was fake right I
thought I thought their virus was made
up like make up your would you
believe in something and then just stay
there for a minute yeah can you just
speaking speaking of that I've got
something to show during mean the
shitless Roundup about this like pick a
lane you're either this or you're that
you can't be both I I would like to see
that um there's another question here
before we go to the list I I don't
know are we talking about breasts now I
don't do can we say we never said
boobies I don't I don't think I said
anything about boobs did we say boobs no
I don't think so BW rock you got your
you get your mind in the in the gutter
or in the cleavage which yeah I'm trying
to think like we were talking about I
don't know
I don't think we've said boobs I didn't
maybe well no you're talking about gear
CrossFit right kid right I didn't hear
it I mean I we could talk about boobs if
you want if that's what we want to do I
mean last week we were talking about
porn so I mean every nothing's off the
table here at the Tony Michaels podcast
uh for sure everybody
I I love the um the shoot the but
we really got to get to the shitless
Roundup I want to see what Gabe Sanchez
hands for us here so let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
s i noticed that thing kind of makes the
Twitter look cool I need to not I need
to change that make it look too cool
doesn't it it does it does make Twitter
seem uh like badass I'll say that much I
mean not so badass much anymore not so
much the the badass now and we can we
can really dig into that one today uh
because yeah I know you want to talk
about to talk about Elon oh I know
what BW rocks was saying Natty fake or
real that's oh I see boobies got it
gotcha yeah
yeah I don't I don't care fake real man
doesn't bother me a bit whichever you
know as uh Steve Carell said in 40 year
old virgin it's like two sandbags you
know
okay what what did you want what'd you
want to show us in the list about
boobs this is not gonna go well this
afternoon there's a there's a couple
things so I'm just getting the second
link but I'll get the first one
um
all right got it okay so what what is
this what am I what am I pulling up here
all right so what you're pulling up here
my friend is
some of this footage from Jan 6 has been
released
um I mean we've seen the January 6
select committee release a lot of it and
the courts have released a lot of it in
evidence right was the sentencing of
some of these scumbags yeah and
Scott McFarland will release new stuff
we've seen you know yeah yeah as the
courts get it this is one of those
um now Colin Colin rug uh who's this
who's this gay conservative cuck
um you know he's a big a big Elon simp
like really eating the boot eating
the boot man oh yeah he is full-on
anti-vaxx pro two-way all that
so you can't you can't tell where he
begins and Elon ends is what you're
saying oh yeah it's head to ass it's
like bam all the way up there
okay Human Centipede you know okay
so so he he uh he shares his video he
goes here is a police officer pushing a
man off a 30-foot ledge on January 6th
will he be held accountable this is the
type of footage the left doesn't want
you to see
let's just correct you I do want people
to see this footage I want people to
know that when you around you find
out but also I want people to know that
there's a staircase right on the
other side and these idiots decide that
they're like it's the video of the one
person climbing up the side of the wall
and they fell all the way down onto one
of the barricades those dumb asses don't
have the foresight to look beyond their
Maga flag to see that there are
stairs because it's a state
capital and there are other ways to get
into the building they think oh no we
got a storm it we gotta climb that whoa
like if there was any anyone
that would ever say climb that wall it
should definitely not be a bunch of
these white racist dicks because they
want to push against you know uh uh
Latinos coming to this country from
other countries uh and saying like oh
they're gonna climb over that wall the
irony of that statement and the
projection from these people climbing a
wall or a staircase on the other side
and then getting pushed off by the very
people that they say yeah back to Blue
we love Law and Order just comply
I don't feel sorry I don't feel sorry at
all Colin walked around you found out
Colin rugger I'd bet would say about
peaceful protests and block highways
you'd be like just run them over right
yeah you're in the road just run them
over and then he's really upset that a
police officer pushes this guy off the
ledge which you know I I don't know if
he broke his legs or not it doesn't look
like 30 feet he's saying 30 feet that is
not 30 feet but I want to show
you I want to show you shits look look
down here look down here when he falls
watch when he falls because it makes it
look like it's really high yeah
but watch how watch how unhigh it
is
he's standing up look he's standing up
right here is probably 10 feet
right no that's probably a little bit
more than 10 feet no no he's
standing there he's almost that's a
basketball that's not a basketball rim
size height right here
no I'm talking about right here see
where my mouse is yeah yeah let's see
when he gets up watch watch when he
stands up
hey no look they're all the way up but
not even okay it's like probably 20 feet
maybe 18 feet at most yeah yeah yeah
yeah 18 feet that's that's like that's
Eve height right
that on a house I just want to watch him
fall again hold on hold on what I want
to know is did he break his leg
um I hope he did I stood right up I hope
he broke both of his inks again
Creator these people they around
and they found out either
that day or they found out because
they're in court now and these videos
are being used against them as evidence
to show hey you guys broke the law you
broke you broke in illegally
is some B and E not only that but also
destruction of of property uh vandalism
and why is Colin against the police
pushing antifa off a wall it it doesn't
make any sense really I mean honestly if
this guy's antifa why is he against the
police pushing him off the wall I mean
that's one of those things that the
Republican party because the Republican
Party knows there they cannot win this
argument of we did nothing wrong right
Tucker Carlson's pushing the conspiracy
that this is just totally
uh it's a nothing burger right he's like
oh no they didn't do anything wrong and
and this is all big conspiracy and
they're lying to you but we're not gonna
let them lie to you and then you find
out I mean obviously because we
literally watched this live that day on
January 6 2021
they're trying to push this idea like
Andrew Clyde it's just a normal tourist
visit there's nothing crazy about it you
know
these people cannot pick a lane you know
one day they're for the police the next
day they're not for the police they're
like oh yeah we should we should fire
those cops the next day we should
protect those cops it's like pick a
Lane already you know it's
getting annoying but also it shows you
that these people don't have any
conscience uh moral compass uh they have
no path that they that they are
committed to walking on right they'll
jump to the other one and take this
argument and jump back it makes I mean
when I say it doesn't make any sense it
doesn't it does make sense because of
who these people are but it doesn't make
sense if you were to like as an alien
come down in a UFO and look at this and
like watch this back and forth you you
would as an alien would probably like
what the this makes no sense like
what what are you doing here like how
are you playing both sides why are you
playing both sides
but Tucker Carlson Kevin McCarthy Paul
gosar margin Taylor green Lauren bobert
Andrew Clyde all of these people all of
these people
uh cannot pick a side if their life
depended on it because today it's there
for it and tomorrow to be against it and
whatever the topic is right there are
four regulation they're not for
regulation well they're for freedom of
speech on Twitter that's why he bought
it right but look I want to show you
this this is the title this is the Tweet
they're censoring this tweet Elon is
today do you think it's because you said
nut
no it's because I said fauci
owns right wing nut jobs now there's
some goddamn parallel universe oh
man look at that Inception Inception no
but I'm telling you man
I'm healing
no no
I I want to I I am a brass to your game
Sanchez hold on let's let me let me see
is that warning come up for me as well
yeah probably it wouldn't let me show
the um the the when I pulled up in the
podcast account earlier yeah because I
don't know if I have that what my
sensitivity um settings are over on the
podcast count it wouldn't even show me
the broadcast it shows the broadcast
does it have a warning on it no it's
just one hour goes as fast she owns
right wing not just well it's because
it's in my account and they put a
warning on it of sensitivity so if
people have their sensitivity
um settings oh my God no sensitivity I'm
insensitive yeah uh I want to
see everything them yeah when you
send me porn I want to see it God damn
it no I mean this is like when I it's
got to be fauchy that's the reason why
probably there's probably a list of
words that uh vouchers
Elon has
personally put in he's like oh what are
these keywords fauci Elon Elmer no no he
ain't doing himself he's forcing he's
forcing his people
the people who love the work for him by
the way oh yeah the people who love to
work for him the people that
lick that person and eat it whole that's
what I said one of those people I just
want to quickly jump into this because
you you touch that topic yeah is uh
Esther
uh Crawford okay right
she was the woman here I'll give you a
before and I'll give you an after oh
okay so this is Esther before yeah this
is supposed to be four okay and then
we're gonna get the after but who is she
who is I guess I guess the the the
picture will give you evidence of the
viral yeah yeah but who is she who is is
she actually
um she works at or worked at Twitter as
the head of payments right so she was a
product uh manager head of payments I
think is what she eventually came up to
um is this after everyone got fired she
worked
yeah yeah pretty much it was one of
those situations where a thousand people
were laid off and they're like who's
gonna take over and they're like who
wants Twitter 2.0 oh and she said I'll
do it as she's like eating the
off of elon's boot
um
delicious delicious this is so good oh
man I love it
um so if anyone remembers
she was the one that uh if I can find
this original link
she was the one there was a photo of a
woman that with blonde hair that was
sleeping on the floor in a sleeping bag
it was like a shared office too yeah
it's a shared office right and so uh
here we go found it she's like sleeping
against the wall yeah she's in a little
corner uh you know there's a there's
it's a conference room she's sleeping in
right she's committed she's giving it
her all people she's really laying down
this uh hustle and grind you know you
Gotta Die for the good of the company
this is her okay this woman who has a
family willingly decided to sleep in the
office which by the way has been
converted into like part hotel for
employees part workspace because they've
got so much space they're selling
they're selling the chairs the tables
the the TV and the is that like a couch
cushion she said it looks like some sort
of mat I don't know anyway so she's in
the office right and and the original
tweet came from an employee that was
like hey I think if you go out of that
real quick because she quote tweeted it
okay let's see Irene she she tweeted on
this she quote Yeah she quote tweeted it
because uh oh this is the part that you
want to see so this is the before yeah
when your team is pushing Round the
Clock to make deadlines sometimes you
hashtag sleep where you work right no
that is very very bad work life balance
I've worked at startups where I've also
crashed at the office but I was a
startup and it was long hours and I was
also in my 20s right and I would say
right now looking back it's like yeah
you know sometimes it's fun because
you're with other people you know you're
drinking you're working you're ordering
food all that stuff and you're
shooting the and you're having a
good time and you're like making these
connections with people
the problem here is this woman
however old she is again has a family a
loved one or kids or whatever
at home and she's like hey honey just
wanted to call and let you know that I'm
not going to be coming home tonight oh
you know what I won't be coming home
tomorrow night or the next night or the
next night or the next night it's
because Elon Fire fired all his labor
she right so she's like honey if you can
take care of the house and our pets and
our family and all that stuff please do
that because I am killing it at work
right now keep in mind this is also
during the time that Elon gave this uh
uh arbitrary deadline is what we'll call
it he said
I want you to change this Commit This to
the code base I want you to uh add this
feature which was later removed and then
added and removed again
um and then later added there's no
product Vision roadmap or timeline other
than it has to get done by this time and
that was The Benchmark if you could
deliver on that you state the company
and you're part of 2.0 right and there
are massive layoffs and then even after
that deadline there were massive layoffs
again they were mad there were another
group of layoffs of 50 or so people this
past weekend that happened again she was
one of them she was one of the people
she was also a tweet after so this is
the tweet that she made yesterday to
justify
dude she again I told you dude she's
she's heating that up in the
microwave she's cooking it eating it
faster she's cutting into uh this boot
and the that is in the just
inside it is like mushed in someone says
who the is Esther Crawford yeah
exactly she's a nobody yeah a nobody
here's thing she's a nobody who stood
for nothing
and committed everything right she
sacrificed everything in fact I haven't
found out here yeah she says the worst
cake you could have from watching me go
all in
on Twitter 2.0 I wonder if that's the
way Elon demonstrated it to him he's
like look you got to go all in I'll buy
you all horsies well here's the thing he
went all in and there were photos that
were released from like all the
engineers they're like oh thumbs up
smiling if you look at the photo there's
like no white people
all of these people look like they're
either from India or South America or
whatever and you're like are they here
on visas and and yeah so there's the
whole visa thing which my question back
then was like
are all of these people like blink
once if you're not okay just give me one
sense of life if you're not okay because
here's the thing you've got these are
people hostage like if there was any
point of like all right look I'm holding
you hostage and you have to stay or else
I'm gonna give up your H1 uh visa and
what you see there is a a rich white guy
who who
um took advantage of people's uh life
and labor so that he could pursue this
dream of owning the lips and even to
this day his product still sucks every
time he only made a product he owned us
this morning
can't freedom of speech no he saw he saw
it was me and he's like oh this we can't
have this guy talking about so then you
see Esther Crawford where she's like I
happily slept on the floor yeah well and
she's like listen to this part this is
the part that really gets me this is the
funniest part about this whole tweet
those who jeer and mock are necessarily
on the sidelines and not in the arena
that's not true what the does that
mean he took people out of the Arena who
were who built Twitter right like the
entire entirety of the actual
international team that built Twitter
and he's destroying it Esther and you
were there along with him you're letting
him do it she was also there was a
Twitter space that was held not too long
after I don't know if you remember this
but there's a Twitter space that was
held on how how Twitter was going to
make money right how they were going to
generate money or in revenue and Elon
went on and he talked about a bunch of
stupid uh where he was like I'm
gonna turn Twitter into a bank where we
can process payments and we can you know
uh take one
uh
exactly right so Brooke here says she
writes federal grants the federal
government encourages H1 Visa hires for
certain job types technology medicine
like at various startups I've had and
I've worked for
we have hired people from other
countries because they were smart
talented and they we worked to get them
H1 visas but there's a you know a
constraint to having the H1 visas you
have to stay employed with a company or
you get another company to adopt the H1
Visa take over you know as basically
your sponsor and so Elon Musk is like oh
look if you don't do the work that I
want if you don't do it to the detail I
want even though my the detail of what I
want is just dumb
and and so ask backwards it doesn't make
any sense but basically Elon is holding
all these people hostage and there were
some people that were laid off who had
H1 visas and they were like what the
do I do now now I'm in a time
crunch to either find someone who can
help me at another company or I have to
move back to wherever country I came
from which again you're putting someone
with no notice no notice you're just
like hey no longer at the company like
there's no like hey look we're gonna
help transition none of that was done
none of that was done
and that's and that's just one of the
many things that Elon did this weekend
which was
fire more people and then still have
people eating and licking like
you know conservative cunnilingus on the
bottom of a boot you know well speaking
of boot lickers it it seems to be a
correlation with these Trump boot
lickers Joe Scarborough is finally
catching on Gabe Sanchez he's finally
getting drunk you know uh so Joe two
week or two ago he he started to bring
up I've been talking about for like
three months let's listen here
to a little bit of this clip this
morning uh when he's talking about I
guess uh Michigan
they voted for a new chair can you look
uh up uh that person's name and
something about them while we listened
to Joe here to the top I don't think no
matter how many miles you say it there
we go it's got Lewis lose
right so say that because they know they
lost in 2017. they know the loss in
2018. they know they lost in 20 years
in 2020. they know they lost in 2020. I
love I love it I I usually listen to
Morning Joe like and I listen to it I
don't watch it
um I I listen to it on SiriusXM sxm but
um
maybe two times a week but I love when
Joe
when he's trying to like half-ass some
man's Lane to Mika's like I just said
that you idiot
said that you it's it's great I
like it 21. they know they lost in 2022.
they know they lost in 2023. they don't
see it yet two of the most important
States Michigan and Arizona what do they
do they appoint people to run their
parties that are what I was calling what
in the world a lot of these Republican
candidates in 2022 and I said Democrats
could win because they're
insurrectionists weirdos and freaks oh
it's it's almost like he's just catching
up here
I I mean I I've been telling you for a
long time the Democrats are going to own
Arizona for a long time because the
crazies has taken over their
party out there there was no clear sign
than that than Blake Masters and Kerry
Lake being the candidates and what was
that box that was the Secretary of
State I I put him out of my memory that
is his name oh in Arizona Mark fincham
yeah fincham that's it yeah yeah that's
it that idiot
um again I I was saying it back then
that the Arizona Republican party is
and they're just completely
screwed yeah Michigan same way
Pennsylvania's getting there uh
Wisconsin's headed down that road but I
mean we had Ron DeSantis in Florida
Banning books and banning the
ability for people to teach children how
to read with books so uh let's finish
here because I want to go to who this
person is that's who they've appointed
there are actually finding people who
are bigger insurrectionists bigger
weirdos bigger freaks to run their
parties and they have MTG
okay okay I I guess you get the point
because you've been listening to me say
this for months why why why Joe
Joe listen man just if you want just
give me a ring I'll tell you what's
gonna happen the next week and then you
can be up to task you don't have to do
it three months from now I'll I'll give
you what what it is going to be in the
next week but this this idea did you
find who they who they uh they elected
as the Michigan GOP head the uh no no
apparently she's a lunatic
she's crazy
um is is the word
and again I I it's not surprising out of
Michigan
um that that you're gonna get some crazy
this is where they tried to kidnap the
governor
uh and hold her hostage this is where
they were they I believe that uh Jack
Smith and he is subpoenaed some State
officials in Michigan uh in this fake
Christina caramo yeah okay that's the
one that Ronald McDaniel doesn't know
allegedly oh she does coffee Ronald
McDaniel Ronald McDaniel says on
uh State of the Union on Sunday she goes
don't know her
she's like you're the head of the you're
the head of this video do you
have that clip yeah I'll get it yeah
that um that will help let's let's see
if we can find that clip uh that's
hilarious that she doesn't know who the
head of the Michigan party is when she's
the national chair yeah uh I got it I
got it here I think dude no that's
something well
we'll play this one your party announced
that the first Republican debate will be
in August in Milwaukee Wisconsin will
candidates be required to sign a pledge
saying that they will support whomever
becomes the nominee in order to get on
that debate stage we haven't put the
criteria out but I expect a pledge will
be part of it it was part of 2016. I
think it's kind of a no-brainer right if
you're going to be on the Republican
National Committee debate stage asking
voters to support you you should say I'm
going to support the voters and who they
choose as the nominee okay I don't know
if I need to provide any more proof now
this isn't the clip we're looking for
but this is proof of what I've been
saying Donald Trump is going to be the
Republican nominee I don't know how much
more clear she has to be here when she's
saying yes we're going to require these
to back him because who's
going to be standing on stage with them
Gabe Sanchez in August Let's see we got
a few months but who's who is it going
to be it's going to be Donald Trump and
who else
who else is running ah is there anyone
else Nikki I mean Nikki Haley okay
and um you know well allegedly
uh Ron DeSantis
oh is he going to is he announced I
don't well again like if he announces it
would be because he can't again he just
took office in January like just you
know reelected in January so it's not
going to be anytime soon maybe in a few
months maybe this summer he would make
an announcement but even so I mean like
we already know that the guy would not
commit during a debate if he was or was
not going to run right we already know
that because during uh during the actual
debates for the governor he couldn't
answer that question so we already know
it's at least a consideration right he's
already he's at least having teams go
out and probe to be like all right what
is the climate right now if people would
potentially look at him as a candid
um
and he's the only other one that could
be a candidate he hasn't announced yet
but right now it's only two people and
it's not going so well for Nick Haley
she's getting a bunch of foot who Nikki
Haley who's that I don't know uh she's a
nobody who uh you know oh she she yeah
that's hilarious she's dug her heels in
for Trump right and then now Trump is
you know right dragging her some people
surmise that she's looking for the vice
presidential a lot of people are like oh
who's gonna be the VP you know people
throughout margin Taylor green not gonna
happen some people threw out Carrie like
possibility but she said she might run
for Senate so we'll see
um you know definitely not gonna be Mike
Pence right could be the fly on my side
you know I think the fly has got a
better chance than a Mike Pence and
really even Ron DeSantis or Nikki Haley
here's what here's what uh they're
they're trying desperately the media and
Republicans are trying desperately to
get this this notion out there that Joe
Biden isn't going to be the nominee
watch this
maybe we have such a great bunch of
candidates I look at the Democrats what
they're doing to limit any competition
to Biden look at the fact that they just
changed their entire primary schedule
they made sure that New Hampshire is
gone from being the first of the nation
primary why because Joe Biden came in
eight so that is a president who's weak
he was worried about Democrats have been
trying to change Iowa and New Hampshire
in the schedule for years and
the reason why is because Iowa New
Hampshire doesn't reflect the Democratic
party I I hate I I hate I hate to be the
bearer of bad news whoa tell all the
Bernie supporters out there but New
Hampshire and Iowa do not do not reflect
what the broad Democratic party looks
like and you only have to go back to the
last primary that was a national
primary to see what happened oh yeah Joe
Biden was done until he got to a state
with a with a huge portion of the
population the Democratic electric that
was black and and it just it just does
not make sense to have Iowa New
Hampshire in the front of the Democratic
primary it does not it doesn't reflect
what the Democratic party looks like
what they want and it doesn't and it's
not it's not doesn't benefit anyone to
falsely make it look like a one of the
Nom one of the candidates is going to be
the nominee when they don't have a shot
in hell in the rest of these primaries
and that's what I'm trying to tell you
about the Republican primary is Ronda
santis doesn't have a shot in
hell in these goddamn primaries he just
does not what is he going to do go out
and and talk about how Donald Trump
stoked violence on January 6 how he
tried to overturn our constitution how
in the is he going to do that he
can't manage that what is he going to go
out and talk about how incompetent
Donald Trump is is that what he's gonna
do yeah uh it's he can't out Hitler him
he won I mean we know that you know
these people have hitched their wagon
uh you know so to speak
for years now under this Trump
this this Trump is is the the end-all
be-all he's got the great policies and
this and that you know and I think many
of them thought
cool Trump's going to either you know
get his term win re-election and then
I'll have my chance after uh once he's
already established enough of this
that they've done that I
could come in with similar policies or
even more damaging or harmful policies
it really really you know Screw
over the American people
and now I think they're coming today
they're coming to the decision of
uh can I wait another four years right
because what happens if Donald Trump
loses right does he accept the loss and
he's too old to run again or does he try
to run again you know if he in another
four years once he loses right have you
heard of Kerry Lake before have you
heard of that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're not going to give up on this
side so that they've lost right and so I
I see people like Nikki Haley and
potentially Rhonda santis and they look
at this and like all right look well if
he loses now then that's another four
years and I don't want to wait four
years so I guess my chance is good as
anything so you're saying that maybe why
he enters this because Trump won't go
away yeah I mean like if you're telling
me right now that Trump there's no way
in my mind I see Trump like he runs he
loses right he's gonna say it's
rigged and all this even though
you know we know that the it was a free
and it was a fair well I don't know if I
would say fair and when I say that
I say not fair because Republicans have
disenfranchised other voters
marginalized communities specifically
some of those people from you know South
Carolina
uh you know basically Republicans if if
you're white then hey no no IDs needed
we trust who you say you are if you're
in the Villages vote a few times I don't
care but if you're anyone who's
darker in your pigmentation
than a white person then everyone gets
carded everyone gets questioned everyone
gets doubted
and so
what I think is happening is
Donald Trump if he loses which I know he
will again in 2020 2024 he's not going
to let go of that he's going to be the
oldest guy running for president
but that that's right so I think that's
why these people have to say look it's
now we're never well I mean I mean if if
you're going to use age as something
against Joe Biden right right think
about 2028 how old Donald
Trump's gonna be yeah I mean think about
think about how many
cheeseburgers and buckets of chicken are
between now and 2028. he's 76 right now
okay
well that's not including a pair of
handcuffs and an orange jumpsuit too I
mean you know yeah no no not at all I
mean we've you know he's 76 right now he
turns 77 in June okay he turned 77 in
June I mean look Joe Biden is 80 years
old right right that's how old he is
that would be how old Donald Trump would
be if he were to assume office now Joe
Biden assumed office before he was 80
but I mean he can run he can run a bike
he can handle a ramp I mean there's
certain things that Joe Biden can do and
so we've got Donald Trump looking at
this he goes oh I'm a strapping young 76
I'm going to be 77 in June I'm gonna run
for the RNC if I don't get the
nomination I'm going to go across the
street I'm going to go on the
independent ticket which is fine you
know what do it oh yeah oh my God I
hope you do there is nothing
better for this country if Rhonda said
if I'm wrong think about this I'm I'm
saying that if I'm wrong it's better
than the situation that I'm saying if
I'm right I don't think that's a good
situation
I'm saying if I'm wrong and Rhonda
Santos is the nominee Trump definitely
is going to try to stay in the races an
independent camera and try to get on
many as many ballots as he can I mean he
he talked about making his own own party
after he lost the election he never did
he well yeah and he fundraised on it but
he never did no but that's because he
owns the RNC that's why he's gonna win
people don't understand we'll win the
nomination well huh win the nomination
yeah yeah that's the election that we
have in front of us yeah yeah the
election that we have in front of us is
not the general election man that's
that's far away the election we have in
front of us is a republican uh nominee
the Republican primary that's why uh
McDaniel is on CNN projecting that oh
well it's again we're gonna have a big
bench and all this nonsense because the
goal of Donald Trump and running the RNC
and having control over them is to make
sure there isn't a bench and he's
already doing that he's calling Ron
DeSantis a pedophile what what
what more of a signal do you need that
Donald Trump is going to do anything he
can possibly do to secure this
nomination is it now you get this clip
is this the clip where she's talking
about the um the committee yeah or the
the head of the head of uh what what's
the name again uh Christina caramo
Christina Karama Okay let's listen here
chair of the party in Michigan uh
Christina caramo
she is an election denier she uh on
January 6th uh talks about the
conspiracies that happened she lost her
Secretary of State Race by double digits
does she represent your party
and will her presence as head of the
party in Michigan hurt your chances in
that very important state you know I
don't know her very well and I wasn't at
this recent convention so the Delta so
so she doesn't know her not only does
she not know her the chairwoman
of the RNC did not go to the goddamn
state where they picked the
leader of the of the RNC right at the
Republican Party the but you have to you
have to acknowledge the argument she's
making right now she's saying she's like
I don't know her I don't know who she is
no no no no no no no no if you're the
head of the RNC you are at the end of
you know the the chairwoman right you
know everyone who is running you know
who is planning to run you know who's
trying to squeeze their way in to get a
bid or to get an endorsement you know
every single person across the country
and even if she's like oh well I don't
remember me here she's met her she's
talked to her or she's been in
communication with someone from her team
you don't just go ahead and run without
the party knowing you're running okay
that doesn't happen even even George
Santos he had to have the local County
he had people at least stefanik went and
stumped for him yeah and so you've got
you've got Ronald McDonald right now
being like Oh I honestly it's like that
Mariah Carey where when they ask her
like oh do you know Jennifer Lopez he's
like I don't know her like that's
literally that moment right now she goes
I don't know her bull you
know exactly who she is you know exactly
what she stands for and so you cannot
you cannot just be like oh you know what
I don't know who she is I've never met
her before I've never talked to her I
don't know where her politics are and
the other thing too is like she doesn't
even acknowledge the fact that she's an
election time she's like oh I don't know
her so it's like you know I I can't say
anything about it well not not the
election denial aspect is a is a loss
like but that's dude that's not a glitch
that's not a glitch that's a feature
because the reason why she absolutely
knows her she knows who she is she knows
her beliefs and she knows what she
stands for is because number one she was
the Republican nominee for
Secretary of State in Michigan in this
last election
Are You Are you
seriously councilman or something right
you're saying that you and and secondly
they're their play for 2024 to to have
another Insurrection at the state level
with these State electors because that's
what their scheme was before so they
were really trying to rig it up with
Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin and
Arizona it didn't work
their scheme to rig the election in
Michigan with the secretary of state
with that bonehead who is now
the rona's best friend who is now the
head of the party in Michigan
was part of the plan to undermine the
2024 election when Joe Biden beats
Donald Trump right that's right that is
glaring here is that the reason why they
wanted to rig all this isn't to rig it
for Ronda santis or Nikki Haley they're
rigging it for Donald Trump people he's
gonna be the nominee
it's it's only more proof well the the
thing I was going to say here is that
she Christina caramo right this crazy
conspiracy theorist election denying you
know Maga uh she's she spoke at at a at
a at a save America Donald Trump rally
okay this isn't a nobody okay this is
someone who is within them are you a
scarf to go there I'm just wondering not
that I know this is a pattern with she's
with Trump making a speech right I can't
find any any photos of of uh Ronald
McDaniel and her the same event I will
try because now uh Ronald McDonald I
don't want to do what was that on this
she tries to stay away from she tries to
stay away from those events yeah that's
why she didn't go to Michigan because
she knew they were gonna pick her and
she'd have to stand next to her
to take a picture with her right yeah I
mean that's that's the uh you know I I
hate to jump topics here no but this guy
hasn't been on our show in a while and
I'm kind of glad he's back to be quite
honest this guy is so easy he's so
easy have you you remember Greg
Locke yeah yeah yeah oh my god dude from
Twitter is he back on Twitter I don't
know but he remember he gave away his
501c3 oh yeah sweating hooting and
hollering
it up you know demons wasn't it revealed
later that people were like he doesn't
have a non-profit no well no they were
stripping him of it because it's no no
no is that what it was no I think if I
remember correctly people were trying to
look it up and they're like this he
doesn't have a non-profit status he I
mean he's a George Santos right he made
up a company said it was a non-profit
but when people looked into it not only
that but he was like all right IRS like
he was he was challenging them
but if I remember correctly and I'll
look this up right now but I'm almost
positive it was revealed that he didn't
actually have a non-profit registered
oh or at least no one could find the one
that was
uh that was under the name of the church
or anything close to it uh someone says
here lock is a q-nut oh that oh look
that's an understatement he makes he
makes Q Anon look and you know
like gloved he's I mean listen to this
I mean we're we're talking about
going all the way back to Salem here
okay listen to this crazy ass
this is what I said earlier about
them losing the plot is they're losing
the plot they're losing reality so much
so that no one's really gonna start to
go along with this listen this is great
we're talking about witches now
literally witches I believe that you
have skills that you've learned and
God's shown you said tell us how do we
deal with
well first of all you have to boldly
acknowledge their existence okay you got
to get away from this long pointy nose
you know green face Wizard of Oz flying
around on a broom idea oh yeah oh my God
there's they are seriously they're they
are talking about witches existing and
that this is the threat as witches I
don't know I don't know if you've um
read any stories or have you been to
like Salem Massachusetts or close by
there or read anything about the Salem
Witch Trials or anything like this we
are literally back in that
stupid timeline
it's 2023
and there are people given this bonehead
money and he's out there going yeah
there's witches everywhere man
listen it's it's fantastic he has he has
he has a certain Seance thing that he
does to cast out the The Witches at his
Services listen this is oh this is
beautiful witches are reality
matter of fact our public school system
is hiring full-blown well-known witches
at an alarming rate Facebook there are
huge huge massive I mean thousands of
people in these witch's covens now
here's what's interesting I I've never
dressed up like a witch so I can
infiltrate a witch's coven and pretend
to be one of them but witches dress up
like Christians and come to churches all
the time what do Christians dress up
like I don't know I mean look Greg like
is he saying white people is that what
he's saying because that's what I hear I
have no idea I mean Patrick Sullivan
brings a good question how can this not
be Rock Bottom I ask myself oh that's
every single day where i'm gonna get way
worse
too low I mean here's the thing he talks
about oh I've never I've never dressed
as a witch and infiltrated a coven but
witches dressed as Christians and they
infiltrate us like look
greglock is a demon
and he has he has done the cosplaying of
a human a very a very uh sporadic and uh
dangerous
demon but he's he's under the guise of a
human right he's a body snatcher and
he's gone in and it may not be uh coven
but it's definitely a cult okay
the guy is a idiot and there's a
reason why
it's just well you said it's a cult and
you said it's stupid it is the cult of
stupid listen to what he does before his
sermons this is oh this is brilliant
just pure classic greglock here uh I
have to make a a standing announcement
every single Sunday night I did it just
last night uh God did not tell you to
lay hands on me and play over me I have
to do that all the time because I let my
guard down a few times and we had some
witches come in lay hands on me and pray
and I'm telling you it Rock wait wait
wait so not only not only do witches lay
hands on him but witches pray isn't that
what he wants them to do I mean in that
I mean in theory you would think you
would think you'd want the witches to
pray you know in like conversion right
you would think that if you were a
pastor or a man of God in the hand of
God wait wait wait you think Greg Locke
is a man of God no this is him
he goes he says greglockos I'm a man of
God God takes his invisible hand and
shoves it right up my ass puts it into
my mouth and he makes me talk these
things yeah that is Greg Locke greglock
is very much for uh
penetration uh Greg Locke
is someone like all Christians who use
religion as a disguise to commit crimes
and then justify them oh well hey look
look I did it I did it for God I killed
that man for God right I stole that
money for God these are the people these
are the people if we want to talk about
a covenant if we want to talk about
witches warlocks whatever
Greg Locke is one of these people he
doesn't have a Coven I mean you could
say his Covenant but he's it's a cult
and the guy is a thief a grifter a liar
a cheat a demon a witch a warlock a
Gremlin a troll whatever you
want to say that's him okay you pull off
the skin like in mission
impossible and you reveal that he
actually has the green skin and the long
pointy nose and he's like and I'll take
your dog too and that's what's going on
that is Greg Locke that is Greg Locke
rock is is the coven I don't I
don't always land on a good uh screen
um look at that that's perfect that's
perfect I'm not even gonna play the rest
of the video because I can't get any
better than than that still right there
holy now I'll tell you that Greg
Locke is a bonehead I mean just
total utter bonehead and he's saying
this you know to get your attention
now many people many people are saying
that Greg Locke is a warlock he he
probably is but here's the thing here's
here's the thing is that
why do I point Greg lockout the reason
why is because of the next video you're
about to see right because uh there are
ministers uh around this country that
are edging up to committing hate crimes
Greg Locke calling people witches that's
crazy and that's funny as
easy to mock it's easy to to pen up
every single Republican and every single
moglodyte out there every election
denier as someone who believes in
witches right that they're all around
and there are people who practice
witchcraft but no one believes that
there's people out there with special
powers that are trying to
manipulate you with their special powers
other than you know the people who gray
Glock griffs but this here this video
here is some pastors that went down uh
to a drag Story Hour in a library yeah
no one was forced to go in and listen to
these people uh read to children they're
minding their own business right right
leave them stay the out of their
business but watch what happens this
this the first part of this video is
great watch this okay
so they threw him out on his ass
um the guy who who went in to make a
fuss at the the library right now I want
to show you the Tweet because this is
important um this is from Chuck
um
um this guy's an idiot he claims to be a
pastor too and yeah uh former uh father
and former candidate
conquesto yeah
he says just he says Justin Pastor Derek
reamer ooh uh physically removed reamer
physically removed from all ages drags
drag queen Story Hour all ages what the
they were reading books to Children
you dumb that's why they're
so triggered they're waiting listen to
this hosted by a library can you believe
this we still have libraries and witches
in this game also this isn't in Calgary
is this where hold on let's I'm not sure
where is this Calgary I don't know if
this is like Calgary as in like Canada
but
but Christianity is under attack it's
under attack
it's under attack
well and again
this is really stupid but here's here's
the rest of the video yeah this is
Canada oh okay well even better
this is even better their hatred is
bleeding out or let me ask our borders
oh he was very hateful very abusive look
uh we do not tolerate intolerance and
punching Nazis should be a new fad I'm
just saying
see and it goes on and on about this and
they they keep calling them demons which
Greg Locke you know continue to call
people years ago and we would mock him
and now he's calling people witches
um it's the same pattern and they're
losing control of the narrative here
they're losing control of the plot
they've lost it and that that is truly
what um
is insane that these pastors these men
of God these people who are trying to
spread love not hate are are going and
actively hating so much so that there
might be charged with hate
crimes yeah I mean they're edging up on
the the verge of being charged with hate
crimes and did you figure out where this
was yeah it's in it's in it's in it's in
uh Calgary Canada okay which
um I'm sorry for any Republicans out
there but that's not the United
States
okay and this guy this
guy uh is from Florida okay the all the
fir almost one of the furthest places
away from Canada this guy is talking
about how a library in Canada
a different country
than the one that he's in
is having story time that they've had I
think if I look this up
you know what concerns me most about
this 77 people I follow follow this sack
of well that doesn't always mean
what you think it means right like I
follow certain people because I just
well I know but 77 God damn I mean I
would expect a couple dozen look this
story time in the Calgary Public Library
has been around since
2018. wow oh this is almost this is
almost five years to the day I mean
granted you know we took time off
because of covet but this was this
article I'm reading was from February
24th so sometime at near the end or
middle of February they launched drag
Story Time hasn't been an issue no one's
been uh transformed into someone
trans or gay or lesbian or queer wait I
thought that's what these words was to
teach people how to
be trans and not read I mean the goal
obviously the real goal is it's just a
gentle fun way to introduce the
conversation to Little People in a way
that's a lot easier for them to
understand right oh you mean teach
children how to read teach them how to
read or you know understand and
understand that maybe there are people
like you know because as a kid right you
may not realize but you feel different
right you're like uh I'm not like
everyone else for whatever reason it
might be you know however I see myself
but as a kid I don't really understand
that yet
so you would think oh yeah it makes
sense to have people around that are
supportive of these changes in the ways
that you are and the ways you identify
right especially he's like I'm there
with my parents my family and I'm there
with someone from the community right
but also the fact that these people yeah
they're just hey I'm I'm playing
a character I'm doing a performance and
I'm reading a book and I'm making it fun
do you want to rather hear me read the
book as as me in this in this drag
Persona this character I have or would
you rather hear stifle dry Susie
right or or uh this cuck dude
try to read or or struggle to read a
book
to a bunch of kids right I want Grace
lock reading the kids I don't even know
if greglock can even read
he yells a lot right he he hears he
hears stuff and he yells
but I don't know if he can actually read
right he's like I read the Bible last
night it's like did you read the Bible
or did someone else read it to you and
you had it on tape oh
oh man they're coming for me uh that our
local library and the mighty librarian
says learn different types of people we
like that we have a librarian on staff
here
um at the Tony Michaels bundle I mean
there's a lot of lessons in circulation
and Librarians are great people to
direct you you know to resources and you
want to do a paper here are the
resources you have go find that money
it's almost like they're professionals
at uh sourcing information it's almost
it's almost like Librarians teach you
how to do your own research
crazy she says Republicans are the ones
who want to close libraries they want to
remove books they want to fire
Librarians they want to teach the very
people
who teach you how to do your own
research the group that says do your own
research I did my own research and
like that
those people those people are the ones
who want to take away that from people
that actually
teach you how to do your own research a
lot of love coming in for like yeah
Librarians are great well they're sexy
um they're they're thanking Mighty
librarian for being our local librarian
so thanks for being here you know Mighty
librarian yeah um well I teach uh mining
librarian says I also teach an
information literacy course
um could you do something about this
person then I would really appreciate if
you could help this one
or maybe this is is this why CrossFit
came up oh yes
in the last two minutes I told everybody
I'd get to this video this is
great oh my God it's 10 15. oh I guess
it's my time man it's almost done yeah
yeah it's we're that close it happened
two hours just like that uh Marjorie
Taylor green says Body Mind and Spirit
be unstoppable
she has a tendency to steal other
people's songs
um and I don't know if um I'm hoping Sia
comes for well I'm gonna turn the sound
off and the reason why is because I
don't want him to come for me and I'm
not gonna
but it is a song that you would
recognize you can watch the clip
but I'm gonna we're gonna talk over this
it's just it's a scene of fans out there
while she's doing this because it really
makes it better without the music
actually we should set this to a
different set of music to see if we can
get this going
um this is the reason why I brought up
CrossFit in the first place is because
of this buffoon
yeah you know you know what I noticed
like this here these uh these wild
CrossFit pull-ups they're they're it's
[Music]
is that what you want is that how you
want the I think I think that's okay so
here here's um these I don't know
there's chin-ups there's Pull-Ups
there's muscle ups where you muscle up
and then there's this CrossFit version
and this is why you know that she does
Crossfit because of this pull-up that
she's doing this is very
um synonymous with crossfitters this
what do you call this uh former
crossfitter uh Dave Sanchez it's a a
Kipping pull-up a what a Kipping
k-i-p-p-i-n-g Kipping what what is the
intent of this pull-up in CrossFit uh
the intent is you're trying to get as
many reps as possible right so you're
she's swinging and going ahead so she's
doing the motion right now there's
there's the monk there's the muscle ups
which are like you're pushing yourself
above the bar all the way above the ball
yeah that's like full that's like okay
we get it uh you don't need to be an
overachiever it's very difficult to do
and a lot of people hurt their shoulders
doing it yeah you have to it takes a lot
of yeah yeah practice and a lot and
especially like because people need to
do it and not only that but like
typically what you'll do is like when
you're training you'll have one side
push up and you'll get the other side
but after time like if you're real good
you'll pull up in just one motion right
so the reason you do this this Kipping
pull-up
is because I mean here in CrossFit it is
considered a it's a considered a rep
right it's a full rep uh you know chin
up to the bar we don't hit it you know
kind of thing and so it's
it's more
a way to get as many reps as possible
right because again remember you have a
fixed amount of time and you're trying
to do as many
endurance training not rep training and
here's why is because like when you're
strength training there's a range of
motion that you want she has there is no
range of motion here she has no none of
her none of her muscles have a range of
motion this is her this is the Kipping
pull-up is literally using momentum to
swing your body weight from one end to
the bar to the other now there are other
margins there are other versions too
like when you're doing this like like
this repetitive motion like that
you know it's the it's the more fluid
there's one that's more structured where
you're slowly going up right and that
makes more sense because you actually
have range of motion yeah and this one
that she's doing she has no range of
motion
she's literally just using her and and
uh
the last one is that's the range of
motion yeah now generally speaking with
your hands in a um I guess you call this
a supinated where they're over the bar
not under the bar
um normally you would just do a pull up
not a chin up a chin up is where your
hands are I guess that's pronated shoe I
don't know what differences but you know
it's it's backwards right right but in
this position you are assuming that
she's training for some kind of athletic
move because when athletes train for
movement they train for certain type of
movements so they have muscle memory and
the muscle and the stretching to do that
movement like football players
um they they do different movement
basketball players use different
exercises because they have different
movements uh baseball players the same a
one famous one very famous example of
this is when Michael Jordan went from
basketball to baseball he was
conditioned for basketball yeah like his
body was conditioned for basketball and
when he went from basketball to baseball
it took him almost an entire year to
recondition his body to the muscle
memory of baseball and he did it faster
than almost any other athlete could
possibly do because he's a great athlete
yeah that's why it's very it's like
Deion Sanders Bo Jackson and a few
others playing two different sports is
crazy
okay Deion Sanders if if anyone doesn't
know the fact that this guy was in a
World Series and also a Super Bowl I
mean the guys I've I mean to this day it
amazes me like the guys just
built different he was able to do one
game on Sunday and then go to another
team and then play during the week and
then keep flipping back and forth
without any sort of you know crazy
massive life and like altering injuries
or like he did it's just amazing like
it's one of the things we're like dude
this guy is like walk on water
in terms of athletic ability because
that is something that you just don't
not it's something you don't see often
right I think the closest thing was
LeBron James was a star baseball player
right and also a star basketball player
and it was one of those things which one
does yeah which one does he do yeah and
and I guess from what I understand was
very good at baseball too he probably
would have been one of the best tight
ends of all time because of the size and
the speed but the point I'm trying to
make here is generally athletes when
they're training for a movement there's
a reason for the movement and
that's why I say range of motion because
a pull-up generally you're trying to
build your muscle or your endurance but
it's more about building your strength
in this in the area of a compound
Movement Like a pull-up or a chin up
right now the other thing is you would
be trying to condition yourself to do
this movement she is only conditioning
herself to do the Kipping pull-up there
is no movement that Marjorie Taylor
green is gonna I mean other there's no
Insurrection move that's gonna help her
with the with the Kipping move movement
okay the only reason why the Kipping
movement matters is the Kipping pull up
as you call it is so you can do more of
them and use your body momentum and use
the strength of the movement to do that
she's only pretending to do pull-ups
here just like she pretends to be a
congresswoman I want to show how you she
pretends to do push-ups too
um now a lot of people get all technical
with with exercise movements but this
this is um a weird a weird situation why
does she go outside to do a push-up in
the first one I don't know there was
plenty of room on the floor right there
this is what happens when you are kicked
out of the CrossFit gym that you
you have to do it look I mean dude
imagine having a driveway that
big
you know like well I mean I mean I'm
just saying like I'm just saying as
someone who doesn't own a home but and
then also other people who don't own
homes are like oh man don't like
the house that she has is on a a decent
sized lot of land
but she doesn't need to go outside you
know she could do it 10 feet away from
the the rack and do it inside the garage
right she's not jumping
not going to jump higher than where the
rack is
she doesn't need to do I don't know it's
just one of those things well and the
other thing husband husband yeah or
actually ex-husband I don't know who's
filming this then who the is
filming this video of the gang the guy
the on Newsmax Guy what's his name oh
right yeah yeah yeah I know I know what
you're talking about
um
but she's pretending to exercise here
she's pretending to strength train the
most obvious one is the Kipping pull-up
because really honestly they're they're
worthless I mean unless unless
you got something to prove in a CrossFit
gym the Kipping pull-up is worthless
you're not really building strength in
your back
um you're only tearing your shoulders up
is what you're doing
um because you're not even really
stretching in a way that that you would
want your shoulders to be stretched
because you got you got you got three
heads on your shoulder
there's the front the back and then the
lateral head and she's really and she's
going after the the uh
it's it's not it's not an exercise
that's helping no and besides it makes
her look stupid and it's like she could
have she she could
uh get more out of the workout right and
I'm not I'm not you know oh wait wait no
wait wait I'm wrong holy okay here
we go so J just I saw the workout
critics here I am I'm a workout critic
Marge you Petty Yeti of my
butterfly pull-ups she calls them
butterfly pull-ups yeah well I mean I
guess the range of motion but those are
I mean they're keeping they're they're
more fluid Kipping pull-ups but whatever
they're done in Crossfit workouts and
should not be done unless you have good
shoulder Mobility oh whatever and and
can complete at least five strict
pull-ups without fatigue oh here we go
here we go strict pull-ups these are
strict
oh Ned's two
now there's three let's see if she does
a strict one here well that's four I'll
give her that it's fit did she get five
when she got five she got five strict
Pull-Ups
there's six
come on come on seven I'm I'm beginning
to be impressed
eight oh my God
uh that's not a strict one I wouldn't
give her nine strict ones definitely not
ten smoked ones definitely not ten three
I give you eight strict Marjorie Taylor
green here's the here's the problem
here's the problem that we have is that
is that is that your ability to do
Kipping butterfly push-ups strict
pull-ups chin UPS push-ups does not
qualify you to be a congress person it
really doesn't
it doesn't qualify you to do anything
besides those things
um and why why she's taking someone
else's music because that's really well
I don't understand why they haven't uh
claimed the copyright yet what's the
music on this one let's see I want to
play this no there's no it's just her
heavy breathing
is there fart sounds oh here we go here
and she's squatting too oh she's
squatting these are old videos though
yeah that's not the same video
so I'm not gonna believe that that's
what she's doing now but the point is is
that she she she's posting workout
videos as if it makes her qualified for
something Unstoppable yeah this whole
idea that somehow because you work out
and you strength train rather using
CrossFit or hit or or bodybuilding or
yoga or Pilates
somehow qualifies you to be a member of
Congress because you have the ability to
get up every morning and exercise is
really dumb what's this that
you're sending me here I just want to
end it on a on a laugh as we before we
oh absolutely yeah this guy I saw this
video I think it was on Instagram
originally and then 50 Shades away Dave
brought it out and put it on Twitter
and I first was like oh this again
but I was like oh no this is It's new
Alpha Male just dropped he said okay so
uh let's see but this is only 15 seconds
so let's see what this is you'll get a
good laughing and we both pull up and we
go to your girl odds are I'm gonna take
that if you compared me to you
you're not gonna win that battle so the
next time you think that your girl's on
lock I got the keys to the castle
no no you don't no you don't look you
barely you you this is you are across
the moat
signaling to the guy in the lookout
tower to be like hey can I come in can I
come in that's who you are no there's no
way that one yeah you own look go go
through uh scroll through a little bit
more
pull up uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh yeah
uh-huh keep going go back that one
you're gonna tell me this cuck
is gonna get a Girl by rolling up in a
car get the out of here
I know you're not oh guys I'm so
hot and probably no you're not the stash
man you're dude it's the
you're look this guy uh whether he owns
the car most likely Rents It Or lease it
like Andrew Tate
uh not oh man somebody says he's got the
David packman stash
people in the comments hating you trust
me I know they they'll come after you
the Packers is that what that is that
what they're called I don't know I don't
know I don't know I'm not sure but this
guy uh wow I bet he has a free mustache
ride shirt oh my gosh well you know
Robbie I I don't know that there's uh
much wrong with a free mustache ride
shirt but when it's on this guy when
it's on this guy there might be
something wrong with it there's no
question mark small dick energy yes yes
there's no question mark it is
exclamation point Goldie says she loves
Pac-Man and we love him here too I just
I wish I wish David would do better
commentary not be so boring so
tell goalie tell David next time you
talk to him to that Tony Michael said
just stop doing boring commentary and
say some curse words every once in a
while have some balls uh do it so who is
this guy what is this is
I mean like I'm sure if I looked it up
I'm sure if I went through the comments
and because they found who he was I mean
look this guy there's high alert right
now there's a drought happening and it's
because of him
um this guy wait wait are you saying are
you saying he makes women uh drier than
Ben Shapiro
look you could have a competition of uh
of a new game show called
who makes me dry and you could have both
of them go against each other also Tim
Poole Tim pool would be in there here's
apparently this same guy
um trying out for for a wrestling oh wow
look at look at that I don't know do you
think he says oh you just been screeched
uh when he like rolled up Screech did
the guy he plays the screen yeah he is
he's died yeah they had a cancer didn't
he or something um
the the I don't know who the guy is I'm
not sure who the guy is I don't really
care who the guy is to me he's in he's
just another Alpha cook he's a nobody
he's a guy that made a video on
Instagram and on on Tick Tock to be like
bro if I pull up in my McLaren I'm
getting that and it's like
said you never okay no one's ever done
that you've never gotten it you gotta go
look over compensating oh the comments
are great oh my God the comments I'm
gonna retweet this so you guys can you
guys gotta go I wish we had more time
yeah because I would I would run through
some of these cameras I just wanted to
share that laugh for the end to really
get your your Monday to get you into the
rest of the second half of the day and
be like oof at least that was great well
today was today was fun it went fast and
we're overtime again as always uh we
appreciate all your support we're gonna
try to get the three hours sometime this
year we promise
um thing that will help is go over to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez check out
what was that and all the extras over
there why you're on patreon.com check
out my page the Tony Michaels just go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels and
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez see the
extras that we have over there our show
will always be free to you free on
YouTube it's free to subscribe Gabe
Sanchez it cost not a nickel what is
that subscribe or the like button and
3.99 free 99 five finger discount
over on YouTube you get Tony and Gabe
so hit that subscribe button hit the
like button also you can follow us on
Twitter for for free 99 not 8.99 like
Twitter blue it's 3.99 you can download
Us for free on Apple's Spotify and
Google that helps us out every single
week you can also follow us for free on
Facebook at ttoni Michaels we're also
we're live at the up wire Network the
upwire.com just go to their YouTube
channel catch them out there and hey let
me tell you something let me just
actually puts money in our pocket for
free I know this sounds crazy right like
wait are you saying I can I you can help
us out monetary then doesn't cost you a
nickel well it didn't cost you a nickel
more than you're already spending if
you're an Amazon Prime subscriber if you
have Amazon Prime you can download the
Twitch app you can log in with your
Amazon Prime account because you get one
free subscription on Twitch you don't
even have to know what twitch is you
don't even know what it is you just get
one free subscription if you log in with
your Amazon Prime account so go over
there and log in give us your
subscription obviously it helps us out
and it doesn't cost you any more than
what you pay for Prime also Gabe you
sent me a sneak peek do we have that
real quick of the pab45 oh yeah yeah
you can put it in
um maybe flash it on the screen yeah
give me give me give me a second give me
a second it doesn't have to be perfect
maybe yeah I gotta on I gotta open we're
gonna be having this up stored at the
Tony michaels.com go get your Surf's Up
merch and get your Rhonda
Santos can go himself and the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty at store not the
Tony michaels.com we went back and forth
with this pab45 the ass 45
and boy the Gabe Sanchez deliver on this
he sent me a sneak peek over the weekend
and I was just um I was excited about
this new design that's coming your way
at store.the30michaels.com with this
ass
um merch but um
no he's gonna load it in here oh by the
way why why were you doing that I like
your hat by the way oh yeah yeah son of
a neighbor yeah I like your hat by the
way we're gonna I'm gonna be making uh
I'll be making I'll make a son of an
immigrant a daughter immigrant you know
you don't identify as you can say child
of an immigrant so this is this is going
to be it's gonna be a thing yeah I think
it's gonna be a thing you know did you
load that in did you load that in I'm
loading it right now where is it at
where is it at where is it man let me
tell you uh it's in there my dude
oh there it is okay I'm gonna flash it
up real quick everyone I'm telling you
you gotta hit this Mark you're at about
the 219 Mark two hours 15 minutes get
ready it's not gonna last long this is a
sneak preview of what will come to be
PAB 45 merch here it is PAB
45. take a look take a look
it's gone it's just like dead it's gone
we're gonna put it on shirts we're gonna
put it on coffee mugs you're gonna have
it with you so stay tuned we will try to
get that design out this week for you
guys to take advantage of that
p-a-b-e45 it's kind of like a Marvel
logo kind of inspiration that was the
inspiration that we had was the Marvel
logo with all the faces of the
superheroes but the face of the
ass there's no superhero in this
image it's just a bunch of weed just a
ass weak ass
oh boy tomorrow's Taco Tuesday in Texas
all Tuesday don't miss it don't miss it
not a single Tuesday you do want to be
here tomorrow same time same place noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the Facebook the books
of face
till tomorrow Surfside
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
them em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon